salut à tous bienvenue à bruxelles c'est
parti pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne dans cette émission je vous
emmène en écosse direction l'île d'agde
exactement depuis quelques années les
habitants ont réussi à faire de leur
petit bout de terre une zone
indépendante en termes d'énergie solaire
éolien hydraulique nous avons été voir
cet exemple d'utopie au fin fond de
l'europe mais d'abord l'actualité la
directive sur le secret des affaires est
en préparation un texte qui risque bien
de mettre à mal l'exercice des
journalistes et des lanceurs d'alerté
voire de les pénaliser alors l'europe
va-t-elle tué l'info c'est la question
de la semaine
à l'époque on avait cru la bataille
gagnée au début de l'examen de la loi
macron un article prévoyait le respect
du secret des affaires un secret des
affaires si bien protégé qu'il allait
empêcher le travail des journalistes et
des lanceurs d'alert voir les
criminaliser la mobilisation fut massive
et l'article retirer mais le législateur
a plus d'un tour dans son sac
revoilà le secret des affaires cette
fois par le biais d'une directive
européenne en préparation objectif
protéger les entreprises pénalisées
l'espionnage rien de plus normal
finalement mais là aussi la liberté
d'information est un peu la grande
oubliée la révélation des affaires
économique et financière qui secoue les
entreprises européennes risquent de
conduire journalistes et lanceurs
d'alert devant les tribunaux avec ça pas
de luxe l'x alors l'europe va-t-elle
condamné la liberté d'informer
et pour évoquer cette question hautement
symbolique c'est philippe lambert ce que
j'ai le plaisir de recevoir sur ce
plateau bonjour philippe lambertz quand
vous voyez un petit peu cette
ce coup de trafalgar de retirer
l'amendement de la loi maquereau en
janvier et le faire revenir par une
directive sur le secret des affaires il
ya un peu un côté
pas très sympa de la part de la de la
commission et des représentants de
l'union européenne je ne sais pas si
c'est de ce côté là qu'il faut chercher
le pas très sympa en tout cas clairement
l'initiative avait été prise en ivo
européens avant même cette fameuse
articles de la loi macro et donc je
pense que lorsque le gouvernement
français fort tactiquement retirer son
article il savait très bien il y avait
dans lanaudière au niveau européen donc
sont pas des ordres et là quels sont les
risques finalement pour la liberté
d'information voit bien que l'idée c'est
de permettre aux entreprises de faire un
petit peu attention sur les questions
d'espionnage de alors on s'est vraiment
pas trop finalement 6-1 juste sur
l'espionnage si c'est le contrôle de ce
qu'il va pouvoir sortir via les brevets
c'est pas très souvent c'est ça le
problème c'est que ce texte en fait très
très vague et à une conception extensive
de ce que c'est le secret des affaires
en fait ce qu'on aurait aimé c'est un
texte plutôt sur la liberté d'informer
avec des exceptions alors pour des
choses très spécifiques
c'est à dire des secrets d'affaires
qu'il peut qu'ils peuvent être de
manière objective considérés comme des
éléments dont la révélation mettrait en
péril le business model d'une entreprise
est donc là on peut se dire oui c'est
vrai il ya des il ya des secrets à
protéger mais donc la règle doit être la
transparence et l'exception le secret en
fait on est dans une logique
complètement inverse on est dans une
logique où la règle c'est le secret sauf
certaines exceptions et ces exceptions
sont définies de manière tellement
restrictif que finalement en effet on a
un régime qui en tout cas ne peut pas
rencontrer notre assentiment qui est un
régime qui rend plus compliquée demain
l'accès à l'information pour votre
profession alors certes sur les lanceurs
d'alert où on a une petite amélioration
du texte de la commission européenne
mais une amélioration assez marginal
donc ça restera difficile je pense en
tout cas plus difficiles si ce texte
devrait être adopté pour les lanceurs
dallaire pour les journalistes faire
leur métier enfin c'est pas le métier
d'être lanceur d'aller
mais on voit bien que du coup une
opération comme luc slicks qui a été
révélée il ya de ça quand même allemands
quelques quelques mois n'auraient jamais
pu être possible sous une législation
comme celle ci alors peut-être et leur
était possible en fait l'idée c'est de
créer un climat de peur de la part
notamment des éditeurs de journaux en
disant attention je ne suis pas sûr que
ce que je fais est tout à fait légal vu
la situation de mon journal et c'est
bien à prendre le relais serait d'avoir
un procès est donc je vais je vais
m'abstenir lâchant que sur celle de la
dissuasion oui sur la chambre ce texte
va permettre de manière systématique
d'attaquer les journaux qui de fait même
s'ils sont dans leur bon droit
d'informer vont devoir avancer des fonds
pour défendre leur langue originale
parce que en fait on voulait qu'on
affirme comme principe directeur de ce
texte la liberté
d'information la liberté de
communication de l'information or ou
d'accès aux informations or on rajoute
un petit adjectifs qui d'illégitime
eumeu donc on pourra avoir révélé des
informations pour autant que ça ça
procède du droit légitime à informer
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on rajoute un
argument ça veut dire qu'il ya peut-être
des droits qu'ils font quand on qualifie
une liberté finalement en réalité on l'a
restreint or cette liberté est qualifié
dans le texte et donc ça c'est quelque
chose d'inacceptable alors je vois sur
le parlement européen a légèrement
amélioré le texte de la commission mais
quand on voit ce que le conseil en a
fait c'est tout juste si les ministres
concernés ne sont pas à la solde de
direct des intérêts du big business en
europe là on voit que donc le rapport a
été voté en commission à faire je lis
hier il ya quelques jours là le problème
c'est qu'on va rentrer en trilogue ça
veut dire en négociations entre la
commission le conseil et le parlement il
ne peut en sortir qu un texte moins dix
ans en tout cas clairement nous avons
choix entre le texte de la commission
qui est un mauvais texte le texte du
conseil qui est pourri jusqu'à l'os et
le texte du parlement qui améliore un
peu un mauvais texte l'osce a le choix
entre mauvais très mauvais ou un peu
moins mauvais mais c'est de toute façon
pour nous un texte qu'il n'y a pas lieu
d'être et on peut se poser la question
pourquoi ce texte
parce que figurez-vous qu'on est en
train négocier un traité alors voilà
avec les états unis est donc le premier
des secrets d'un flic qui ont fait de la
question des secrets d'affaires un des
points qui veulent absolument négocier
avec leurs dans le cadre du type donc
les dombes libre-échange exactement et
donc et donc les gouvernements européens
veulent rendre la mariée européenne plus
séduisante à l'égard du gouvernement
américain mais en réalité à l'égard des
milieux d'affaires tant américains
qu'européens parce que les secrets
d'affaires existent aux états unis et
qu'ils sont ils vraiment contraignant
clos sur la protection du secret de riz
et surtout il n'y a pas de règles
européennes donc négocier règles au
niveau national faisait rage chaque
tuile aigles y en a 28 et donc c'est
évidemment assez embêtant pour la
commission européenne de négocier avec
les états unis alors qui a pas de
standards européens ils vont devoir
tenir compte de plein de standards
nationaux et donc tout ça est compliqué
donc l'adoption de ce texte ne vient pas
à n'importe quel moment il vient en
pleine discussion avec les américains
sur le type de manière à pouvoir
conclure à la fin veut un accord sur ce
sur ce volet là mais là je dois dire que
il ne s'agit pas de la gentille europe
la sympathique euros contre les méchants
safi enseignant il s'agit bien d'un
combat je pense entre la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'information et
la volonté des multinationales de
protéger les intérêts de leurs
actionnaires et leurs intérêts
financiers et donc c'était une bataille
de la démocratie contre le pouvoir de
l'argent alors pour ça que ça t'a combat
absolument centrale alors justement il
ya eu dans ce combat dans cette bataille
un dernier épisode il y a quelques jours
ici même en parlement européen il devait
y avoir un vote sur le type en un vote
qui a été reporté sur décision du
président martin schultz président
socialiste démocrate de ce parlement qui
a provoqué un tollé tel que on a
rarement vu ça au sein de l'hémicycle où
tout le monde brandissaient des
pancartes et c est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer les fondements de ce
report qu'est ce qui sépare fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe nourrir nous
vivons en europe sous un régime de
grande coalition entre la famille
conservatrice chrétienne démocrate et la
famille social-démocrate entre elles au
niveau des chefs ils se sont mis
d'accord que ils veulent absolument
faire le traité transatlantique or ce
consensus sous les coups de boutoir de
la société civile et révélation qui sont
parfois difficiles à obtenir sur la
nature des négociations sur les
objectifs poursuivis l'opposition dans
la société civile est en train de
grandir dans une série de pays comme
l'allemagne la france la belgique les
pays-bas l'autriche et qu'avant sur la
question des tribunaux arbitraux sur au
fait sur la question du logiciel de
bahreïn ce traité qui est de donner de
faire du droit au profit le droit qui
subordonne tous les autres qui se
superpose à tous les autres autrement
dit nous aurions droit à une bonne santé
à condition que cela n'affecte pas
négativement le profit de monsanto nous
aurions droit à la liberté d'information
à condition que cela n'affecte pas le
droit au profit des banques on aurait le
droit d'interdire la cigarette à
condition que philip morris continue à
faire des bénéfices autrement dit le
droit ou profit devient le droit privé
prééminent et les les tribunaux
arbitraux c'est une manière de
concrétiser ce droit aux profits
supérieurs du drop du prodige bleus le
droit au profit qui serait supérieure à
tous les autres droits donc l'opposition
aux ventes donc la famille socialiste
commence à se fissurer et d'eau pour
cacher ce manque de consensus et surtout
pour ne pas courir le risque de voir le
veut en fait le tdi pena peut-être le
plus de majorité au parlement - on a
voulu et en fait étouffer la faire sauf
que évidemment cette affaire va revenir
au parlement européen et je ne vois pas
très bien comment
les choses ont changé parce que si il ya
eu en effet de la décision unilatérale
de martin schultz la semaine dernière
d'annuler le vote afin de reporter le
vote c'est que ça radicaliser et
peut-être ce qui donnait encore plus
agrégé à ce qui est déjà contre toutes
les personnes qui après celle qui
accepte pas ces mesures là est donc
aujourd'hui je suis convaincu que
lorsqu'on regarde rationnellement ce qui
est en train de se discuter le ttp est
quelque chose que l'europe ne peut pas
fait donc pour vous il est mort né je
pense qu'il est mort-né en tout cas il a
commencé à vivre c'est encore un embryon
alors certains diront qu'on peut pas
tuer les embryons mais sur ce coup ci je
pense qu'on peut y aller sans hésitation
je constate que l'opposition était ip
commence à dépasser les cercle des
suspects rituel où et comment se fait-il
que en belgique par exemple en belgique
francophone les organisations
représentatives des pme et des
agriculteurs ont pris position
ouvertement contre donc la commission
avoir loupé le noir cette année pour les
rythmes et moyennes entreprises
évidemment n'importe quoi il s'agit d'un
traité pour les multinationales et donc
l'opposition tti pays commence à
dépasser le cadre habituel des opposants
au traité de libre échange alors il ya
un autre sujet qui occupe énormément vos
confrères et au conseil et à la
commission est ici au parlement c'est la
question des migrants qui va être
discutée lors du prochain conseil
européen il ya quelqu'un qui a mis un
petit peu son pavé dans la mare ya
quelques jours on écoute c'est un
représentant des nations unies
je félicite l'union européenne pour sa
détermination aborder l'immigration de
manière plus compréhensive et des
missions de sauvetage intensifiée dans
la méditerranée mais je serais heureux
de voir des mesures plus radicales pour
intégrer l'idée que l'union européenne a
besoin et devrait accueillir plus de
migrants à tous les niveaux de
compétences
l'union européenne a des moyens de
donner l'asile sur un certain nombre
d'années à un million de personnes
réfugiées venant de zones de conflit en
syrie et ailleurs
cela ne représenterait que 0 2% de sa
population
on blague là en fait un million de
personnes sur le territoire européen est
ce qu'on est vraiment la capacité
d'accueillir autant de paires par an
évidemment enfin écouter regarder le
liban aujourd'hui accueil des réfugiés
syriens à hauteur d'un quart de sa
population parlant de 0 2% part de 25%
alors clairement ça c'est déstabilisant
pour une société et on comprend les
problèmes que ça pose ici on nous dirait
que accueillir un million c'est à dire à
5 centièmes de la taille de la
population européenne sans ça que ça
déstabilise ray les populations l'année
sont les moyens économiques devant
fernand ajouté quand on voit que je
trouve que ça brille en ce moment où on
a un espèce par le risque étant d'avoir
un sangatte à l'intérieur de la capitale
française est-ce qu'on va pas un peu
trop loin enfin est-ce que je pense que
là on frise l'insultent l'europe et à
des continents les plus riches du monde
le petit problème c'est évidemment que
la richesse européenne est répartie de
manière de plus en plus inégale et que
lorsque 25 % d'européens sont en risque
pauvreté et l'exclusion sociale ils
s'inquiètent parce qu'ils se disent mais
s'apprécie on va laisser arriver en
europe des plus précaires que nous et
donc en fait on a un système qui crée la
concurrence entre les précaires et les
plus précaires encore donc on ne peut
pas poser la question de l'accueil
justifié et je rejoins le boulot point
de vue de deux des nations unies là
dessus on peut pas poser de problème de
l'accueil de migrants et de réfugiés en
europe de la question la justice sociale
c'est clair que on nous a dit d'accord
avec matteo renzi quand il dit si ça
continue comme ça si on réforme pas les
règlements qui font que c'est au pays
d'entrer évidemment entièrement à dire
on ne peut pas dire l'italie à malte à
la grèce alala à l'espagne eux
débrouillez vous les gars ça n'est pas
acceptable
les européens doivent faire preuve de
solidarité et j'ai été très choqué de la
réaction notamment de manuel valls en
france aussi de david cameron ont en
grande bretagne deux pays quand même
qu'ils sont des pays riches dans l'union
européenne qui tolèrent beaucoup de
pauvres parmi eux mais qui sont très
riches et donc qu'ils ont les moyens
j'ai été très choqué de voir nous ne
voulons pas entendre parler de politique
de répartition non solidaire donc non
solidaire absolument mais donc nous
devons nous poser la question de comment
est-ce que nous nous organisons pour
accueillir comme disait michel rocard
pas toute la misère du monde mais notre
juste part de la misère du monde et
comment faisons nous pour rendre cela
acceptable à nos concitoyens qui estime
en effet qu' aujourd'hui des inégalités
explosent il faut en même temps agir
pour réduire les inégalités à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne pour
pouvoir être en état d'accueillir
exactement merci beaucoup avec grand
plaisir aux bears nous on continue
direction les causses figurez vous qu'il
y a eu ni lin qui depuis quelques temps
est totalement autonome en termes
d'énergie on a voulu voir comment ça se
passait et c'est un reportage de samia
déchire
c'est à bord du ferry qui relie la côte
ouest de l'écossé au petit il que l'on
parvient à aig un petit bout de terre
isolée de 30 kilomètres carrés devenue
emblématique car il a été racheté par
ses 90 habitants qui en ont fait une île
presque autosuffisante en énergie
renouvelable
bonjour bonjour nagui ça va je vais bien
ce matin c'est maggie five qui est sur
la vente des cartes d'électricité elle
est l'une des figures de l'île d'aig
10.50 voilà ta moan r c'est parfait
quand elle s'est installée ici le
système fond si écossais étaient encore
fait audel
avant lille appartenaient à des
propriétaires successifs qui ne vivait
pas et qui n'assurait pas aux habitants
la sécurité du logement c'est devenu un
vrai problème pour les gens d'ici il
finissait par partir
donc on a décidé collectivement qu'on
voulait avoir plus d'influencé sur la
façon dont il été géré
les îliens se lance alors dans un pari
un peu fou racheter leur île grâce à un
appel aux dons il récolte un million et
demi de livres en 1997 le rachat est
finalisée mais toute l'énergie de l'île
est fournie par des groupes électrogènes
commence alors un nouveau défi
l'électrification
relier lille au réseau électrique
national par un câble aurait coûté des
millions de livres et aucune compagnie
d'électricité n'aurait fait ça pour si
peu d'habitants ça n'aurait pas été
rentable avec seulement 40 foyers
les îliens décide alors de faire avec ce
qu'ils ont du vent du soleil mais
surtout beaucoup d'eau
nous allons sur la principale turbines
hydroélectriques qui est au nord de
l'île à côté de la ferme de l'aig fort
jeune et l'un des architectes du réseau
électrique de l'île s'il tient à nous
montrer cette turbine alimenté par un
barrage c'est quelle est la pièce
maîtresse du système
ont produit notre courant grâce à trois
sources d'énergie renouvelables
hydroélectrique le photovoltaïque et
l'éolien on transforme cette énergie
grâce à un système qui fournit
l'électricité à chaque foyer avec ça on
arrive à produire au moins 90% de
l'électricité qui est consommée sur
l'île à
mais l'énergie renouvelable ne peut pas
être produite on continue il faut donc
là stockée dans des batteries
chaque jour et 10 et ses collègues
mesurent leur niveau de chargement ça
devrait plutôt bon pour
l'hydroélectrique aujourd'hui non
si l'énergie renouvelable vient à
manquer c'est un groupe électrogène qui
prend le relais
si le niveau d'énergie est trop bas on
peut prévenir la population de deux
manières soit grâce au cloud qui est sur
la jetée à côté du magasin où tout le
monde va faire ses courses ou alors on
envoie un email aux habitants pour leur
demander de faire attention à leur
consommation
le système repose donc sur la
responsabilité des habitants marie tient
un bed and breakfast grâce à des
subventions elle s'est équipé en
appareils peu gourmands en énergie
je continue quand même à faire très
attention
par exemple je ne met pas en marche trop
d'appareils qui consomment beaucoup
d'électricité en même temps
aujourd'hui un kilowatt revient à 20
pence soit deux fois plus que sur le
continent mais c'est aussi deux fois
moins cher que lorsque marie utiliser un
groupe électrogène c'est beaucoup moins
contraignant parce qu'on n'a plus à
s'occuper du diesel pour le groupe
électrogène le faire venir de malek le
transférer d'un bateau dans des bidons
tout le temps allumer et éteindre le
groupe électrogène donc ça nous a
vraiment rendu la vie plus facile
l'électrification de lille a changé le
quotidien de ses habitants mais le
système a coûté cher plus d'un million
et demi de livres financé pour moitié
par l'union européenne à l'époque c'est
yann river qui s'est chargé de récolter
les fonds nécessaires
au bon moment pour construire ce système
de financement européen qu'on avait
reçue venait d'un d'un programme du
fonds régional de développement européen
qu'elle et s'achever il restait plus de
760 milles pense à dépenser donc on a pu
bénéficier de toute la somme
on a eu beaucoup de chance si ça avait
été un enfant ou un an plus tard on
aurait eu beaucoup plus de mal à trouver
l'argent
dans un archipel où aucune il n'est
relié au réseau électrique national
elle a été pionnière mais si l'utopie
d'une autosuffisance énergétique est
possible pour une centaine d'habitants
elle semble difficilement applicables à
l'échelle de tout un pays
bonjour quand il ne pas bonjour bonjour
à toutes et à tous merci à vous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on viens de
regarder ce reportage sur l'île d'elbe
en écosse qui apparaît comme un peu une
forme d'utopie au niveau européen est ce
que c'est un exemple qui pourrait se
généraliser selon vous c'est pas une
utopie c'est une réalité il ya beaucoup
d'autres exemples comme celui là et bien
sûr que ça pourra se réaliser j'emploie
même pas le conditionnel ça va se faire
c'est l'avenir c'est pas une utopie
c'est la réalité d'aujourd'hui et
surtout de demain oui mais on voit bien
que rien que pour ça tu il a fallu
débloquer 800 mille euros pour une
centaine d'habitants oui parce que s'il
a les moyens parce que c'est tout petit
et que effectivement c'est beaucoup
d'investissement pour peu de gens mais à
la limite il aurait été de 10 milles sur
l'île je suis pas sûr que
l'investissement a été beaucoup plus
important
oui l'orne aurait fallu un peu plus mais
ce qui compte c'est les installations
première et puis le réseau c'est ça qui
coûte de l'argent bien sûr qu'il faut y
aller alors en france c'est très
difficile comme vous le savez il ya
quand même de très belles réussites
soit déjà réelle je pense à montdidier 1
que tout le monde cite dans la somme qui
est une commune quasiment autonome sur
le plan énergétique
je pense aux gens du mené 1 en bretagne
je pense à la région nord pas de calais
qui ont ensemble ce cas son master plan
pour aller vers une autonomie complète
en 2050 il y à bien d'autres bien
d'autres exemples donc c'est possible
mais par contre ça c'est pas possible
parce qu'elle raisonnable parce qu'on a
une disposition stupide et dans le
rapport que je viens de randa madame
royal nous en citons quelques-unes qui
en perd sur l'économie voilà ça
s'appelle les acteurs du nouveau - des
chacun peut télécharger le rapport sur
le site adn monde.fr
donc on peut pas parce que il ya une
disposition législative qui interdit à
nos îles de faire plus de 30% de
renouvelables c'est d'une débilité
profonde mais si c'est que la sas idée
de cette législation ben c'est le
législateur mais la question serait
plutôt qui le lui a demandé donc
j'imagine edf bien sûr entre les lignes
d'accord gestion clame fait clairement
on a un lobby l'électricité en france
qui ne nous permet pas d'accéder à ce
type de marchés d'énergies renouvelables
il ya une forme d'autonomie tic le plus
le plus grave je dirais c'est qu'on est
en train de passer à côté des filières
industrielles qui sont en train de se
développer de manière massive
je veux dire le solaire l'éolien mais
surtout le solaire parce que nous
faisons une fixation sur
une industrie nucléaire qui est un
problème en france et dans le monde
parce que les yeux c'est la majorité du
mix énergétique français est largement
mais l'idée que leclerc est une grande
énergie d'avenir c'est absolument pas
vrai du tout on est en régression dans
le monde entier alors même s'il y en a
en chine et en inde quelques-unes
partout ailleurs on ne ferme et plus on
en construit plus elles ferment les unes
après les autres alors elle s'appelle
gaz de schiste dans ce cas l'un venant
c'est le cx-9 unis viennent de devenir
le premier producteur d'énergie au monde
ce qui rebat complètement la junte
entend bien j'entends bien mais on parle
beaucoup du gaz de schiste aux états
unis qui est plutôt en difficulté à
cause de la baisse du prix du pétrole
mais on parle pas de la fantastique
évolution des états unis sur le solaire
vous avez actuellement en construction
dans le texas une des plus grandes
centrales solaires au monde qui va
sortir un coup de la haine et une
électricité à un coût qui est celui du
charbon donc c'est ça l'avenir quand
vous aurez ça plus l'efficacité
énergétique ses terres la réduction de
la consommation plus le stockage alors
là c'est un peu je dirais artisanale
mais on va vers du stockage beaucoup
plus industrielles mais à la question
sera résolue et ceux qui auront pris ce
virage là sur le plan industriel ce
seront les leaders et ceux qui comme
nous ne le prennent pas on sera les
loosers et moi je me bats précisément
pour que ça ne soit pas le cas alors
justement vous avez remis ce rapport non
pas à madame royal mais à son ministère
dans le cadre de la coop 21 es ce que
vous avez
je dirais encore confiance dans la
capacité qu'ont les états d'europe et a
fortiori du monde a travaillé à plus
d'efficacité énergie je pense que il va
y avoir des choses à la coop 21 la
caisse mais je dirais deux choses la
première c'est pas est ce qu'un accord
est ce qu'un appât y en aura c'est le
niveau de l'accord et les cas comme le
nèg l'accord avait quand même été
globalement enfin c'était un peu un peu
tiède un petit voile a été très très
faibles donc où va-t-on être capable de
mettre la barre mais je dirais que la
bonne nouvelle c'est la transformation
de la société civile ce que nous avons
voulu dix ans dans ce rapport et qu'est
ce qui se passe dans le monde sait
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les villes ce
sont les entreprises ce sont les
citoyens qui s'empare du sujet et qu'ils
sont en train de réaliser ce nouveau
monde qu'est le mariage du digital et de
l'environnemental parce qu'on ne peut
plus séparés l'un de l'autre vous ne
pouvez pas faible efficacité énergétique
vous ne pouvez pas faire du stockage
intelligent vous pouvez pas faire les
havrais d'innovation s'il n'y a pas
d'innovation il n'y a pas ce mariage du
digital et de ce souci de réduire notre
pression sur le carbone parce qu'il va
falloir arriver à une neutralité carbone
et de manière plus générale sur les
ressources naturelles là quand vous
dites que c'est au civil c'est aux
citoyens de s'emparer de cette question
et on voit bien que c'est ce qui se
passe est ce que ça veut dire que à
terme et c'est peut-être que vous pensez
que ce sera dans l'urne via des actions
citoyennes qu'on arrivera à faire plier
le politique face aux lobbys que sont
les industries énergétiques
dans l'urne où je dirais tout simplement
par un déferlement parce que quand on
aura fait la bascule n'aura plus grand
chose à faire en allemagne la bascule
elle s'est faite par les citoyens c'est
vous savez que les alains se retourner
au charbon un peu oui pourquoi ils sont
passés du gaz au charbon c'est le
problème nucléaire parce que le charbon
est bien meilleur marché que le gaz ils
sont en train de faire un peu marche
arrière mais ce qui est intéressant en
allemagne c'est de voir que 50% de
l'électricité est possédé par des
citoyens ou des collectivités locales
ces dons via des centrales métal yen
notamment du méthane du solaire de
l'éolien de tout ce que vous voulez et
ça c'est formidable parce que c'est de
l'activité économique locale c'est du
rapprochement entre le producteur et le
consommateur
c'est des synergies locales intelligente
et c'est ça qui fait marcher l'économie
qui créent des emplois et qui donne
l'indépendance énergétique à laquelle
nous devons évidemment inspiré au niveau
européen vous êtes ancien député
européenne corinne lepage on parle
depuis des années du marché unique de
l'énergie de la capacité pour l'europe
d'acheter ensemble pour pouvoir peser
est ce que vous y croyez
c'est très difficile parce que les
intérêts sont si divergents on est parti
dans l'idée que certes il y avait une
robe de l'énergie mais que chaque état
membre est est libre de son mix
énergétique
résultat des courses évidemment les
pressions vis-à-vis des acheteurs
potentiels ne se font pas puisque chacun
a sa propre politique et malheureusement
le projet juncker qui était pas mal sur
l'europe de l'énergie a plus ou moins
été torpillé la france ya pris largement
sa place hier
parce que la france trouve et qui avait
passé de parts pour le nucléaire est
trop pour le renouvelable sauf que
aujourd'hui une majorité en europe est
très clairement pour aller massivement
vers le renouvelable et investir dans
ces domaines a tout simplement parce que
l'efficacité énergétique c'est du
bâtiment c'était désolant emplois non
délocalisables exactement parce que les
énergies renouvelables c'est des
énergies locales personne peut vous
piquez le soleil levant où l'eau la
biomasse et derrière c'est une nouvelle
activité économique c'est l'activité
c'est l'économie circulaire c'est
l'économie de fonctionnalité c'est tout
ce nouveau monde qui se met en place un
c'est très enthousiasmant parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui font ça ce qui est
très important c'est de changer
d'échelle et de faire la bascule exemple
comment ça s'est passé avec blabla
carreau avec rb n b c'est exactement la
même chose il ya un moment donné du
temps où ça bascule parce qu elle
suffisamment de gens pour que ça
devienne le modèle dominant en quelque
sorte nous sommes dans un domaine modèle
dominant du xxème siècle il faut que
nous passions à un modèle du 21e merci
beaucoup à l'énergie et je rappelle donc
que votre rapport est en ligne et donc
lisible par tous le monde partout - vous
allez peut-être créé des vocations alors
par tout le monde avec 1
maudit ce modèle participatif et la
possibilité de s'inscrire sur un certain
nombre de propositions que nous faisons
eh bien écoutez rendez vous est pris
merci beaucoup merci à vous
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis rendez
vous la semaine prochaine avec katia ici
même quant à moi je vous retrouve à la
rentrée ciao
quoi